[Applause]
hi where's ryan d at
did you do this
your boy did
are you garbage if you turned your
garage into a sun
room how would you take the roof off how
do you even do that
that doesn't make any sense
wait that's not a sunroom that's a
garage
with the door open
well you think you pour some lemonade
and put some cheese lounges in there
that's garbage you think that's a
sunrise
that's crazy dude
you put a couple books in the bathroom
have you seen the library it's
unbelievable
it's unbelievable
a sun room
is this the place you guys all live in
now
you guys all share a house
you know they're talking to girls at the
bar you want to come back and check out
the sun room there's a foosball table in
there too
we call it that when the sun hits your
eyes when you come out in the morning
and you're all [ __ ] up yeah it doesn't
really work at nighttime it's not a
sunroom did you put a skylight in or
anything
look out
these [ __ ] dirt balls are sitting on
a couch in a garage and have convinced
themselves they built a sun room
what in the motherless [ __ ]
it's albany
man an albany sun room needs to be a
thing moving forward
you know if we put a fan in here we can
call this a ski resort you're aware of
that
three beds two baths in an albany
sunroom
i can see it on hdtv now
the renovations they just opened the
garage up
surprise
i didn't know it could open
ah that's the craziest [ __ ] i ever heard
man
that's nuts dude
this sun room
the confidence they built a sun room
when they opened the garage door
that one piece of construction done they
put the couch in
he didn't take a wall out or
install a window
like what's the wallpaper situation in
there
why would you think that's a sun room
what's wrong with you people
his face
[Applause]
is basically
[Applause]
well you got us there man
it's a sunroom it's a sun room
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the sun room until about three o'clock
[ __ ]
guys clap it up for ryan one time let
him [ __ ] hear it give yourselves a
round of applause that's our [ __ ]
show guys you've been absolutely amazing